pay attention
pay attention
pay attention to this church pay
attention to this song
pay attention to this prayer
pay attention to this supplication
pay attention to this baptism for this
for this is a baptism this is us friends
spinning away this is us this is life
set to the song spinning away a hymn
that evokes the sacred brian eno's
classic remixed
turned into church
turned into
cinema at its most holy
turned into a cathedral of the senses
cinema you enter friends we are spinning
away friends
this is a the feeling of a great movie
this is the romantic abandon of a summer
day this is an endless summer
this is
effervescence
and the sunset
our veneer the golden hour veneer this
is the song that is the prayer
that is the
the thing that takes the pain away
this is where we heal
this is where we bask in sunlight
this is where we bathe ourselves in
light he who must save his life don't
you see must first lose it
whereas once we were blind now we can
see
whereas once we were blind
now we are awake
the other side of the rainbow the hunt
for buried treasure the pot of gold
tumbling down the rabbit hole don't you
see i went to god just to see and i was
looking at me
do you see
it is we
up on the hill
we are spinning away
ah
the pale moonlight
and the stars and the stars and the
stars my friend
and the stars
oh we are free like jonathan livingston
siegel
we free the brave reckless gods within
us all
in the sky
and the stars
and the sky
and the sky
and the feet the dangle in the sky
that free the brave reckless gods look
at them oh
look at them
look at them
look at the all beautiful baptism of
starlight and
humanity the intersection of our
divinity and our mortality and we are
free
we are free
we are free we are free we are free
oh feel the organ music build
[Applause]
[Laughter]
smile at the sun
smile at the sun
the writer's futile yet noble effort to
fit the world in a sentence
but a song
but a song
but a prayer
but a prayer
the world
[Music]
in a prayer in a song
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
woof
[Music]
you